philip warham asks he may have spoken
about this already but ask him about
prepping especially for climate change
and emp
solar storms
yeah um
so i'm sorry to burst the bubble here
but
i think prepping
if you see prepping as
building a bunker in the backyard
having a set of shotguns and various
guns having your store and being ready
to to protect your land as the way to
prep because that's what i
originally saw as preppers
preppers now will say no that's not us
we're just we're just having good
supplies on it so all right well then we
have to define preppers in my brain
preppers is the guy building the bunker
okay so let's just just go with that i'm
not talking about people who are getting
themselves prepared
see that's how i interact because i
don't know about this word prepper
yeah so no preparation so
being prepared
of course it's a that's a no-brainer
but the other version i think i think
they're very very foolish individuals
first of all whatever goes down
we're not going to be ready for it
you know you get oh i'm going to go out
i'm just going to hunt deer and fish for
for walleye and i'll be sad yeah and if
the lakes are full of acidification and
the deer have died because of
you know radiation really
no you're not um i'm going to sit here
in my bunker and protect myself really
so if your
12 year old daughter comes to you and
tears and and says can my best friend
and their family come and live with us
because their house was was ruined in
the disaster you're going to sit there
with a shotgun and go no stay away no
you're going to let them in so
i think a lot of the hardcore prepper
stuff is just [ __ ] and silly and
nonsense and small-minded
[Music]
and also by the way everybody else who
has a bunch of guns also knows who has
all the food
and we know you have all the food
so and we have bigger guns you know what
i'm saying it's just it's a silly
situation
but um
i think better than being prepared with
food on hand
i think better than being prepared with
spare clothing and equipment and this
is being prepared with skill sets that
enable you
to survive through whatever
if you were just there in your clothes
how to be adaptive how to how to find
things how to you know scrounge things
that to me is stronger and then
secondarily yes
i have a lot of food in my basement yes